we're going to begin with that huge
winter storm you've heard about it
stretching from coast to coast there was
already a lot of snow on the ground in
the midwest parts of Six States are
expecting blizzard conditions more than
75 million Americans are under winter
weather alerts in 29 different states
yikes we're talking bitter coals strong
winds and heavy snow and ice over the
next few days
it's not going to be pretty Christina
raffini is in Minneapolis where the
governor has already already declared a
state of emergency Christina good
morning what's going on there
uh well it's cold uh good morning uh you
know
here the storm isn't on its way it's
already here a lot of what you're seeing
around me hit last night right now the
the city is kind of in between gusts and
bracing down the streets are empty
school has already gone remote here in
The Dakotas and across Wisconsin because
they're expecting record-breaking snow
snowfalls frigid frigid weather and a
whole lot of travel related chaos
the winter blast is whipping across the
country barreling through the Rockies
causing near whiteout conditions for
drivers in Utah Downing trees and
knocking out power lines along the west
coast snow piled onto this highway in
Idaho in just hours
the Blizzard's Bullseye is now over
Minneapolis we are bracing for what is
likely to be one of the largest
snowstorms in Minnesota History the
National Weather Service is predicting
up to 45 mile per hour winds and
difficult or even impossible driving
conditions for travelers
Minneapolis-St Paul Airport a major
Delta Hub is bracing for the possibility
of widespread cancellations most
Airlines here have waived cancellation
and change fees the Twin Cities are no
strangers to snow but this storm could
drop nearly two feet the most since
2010's Dome Buster when 17 inches
accumulated so fast it collapsed the
inflatable roof of the Metro Dome this
is indeed going to be a historic storm
it's going to be a tough storm
I've got some bad news for the kids of
this area although in-person school is
canceled unfortunately or fortunately
the Wi-Fi and power lines are still up
so remote learning is on the schedule
Nate
Christina thank you